[Music]
just one voice in hundreds of thousands
young and old marching under sea of blue
flags a tide of people trying to
redirect the course of history as ever
placards competed for the most
imaginative rebuke to brexit and those
who are driving changed the deal they're
voting on today is essentially the same
deal that he voted against six weeks ago
and so there's so much hypocrisy we were
only at the withdrawal stage so it's a
step towards leaving that's what you're
objecting to protesters claimed to have
taken over the city certainly they
filled London's broad avenues as they
march towards Parliament square which
was filled to a squeeze but for what one
famous campaigner seemed defeated it's
behind the scenes as speakers lined up
to take to the stage organizers knew
Parliament could be on the brink of
accepting a deal
well what's gonna happen is we're going
to get that fired by Brett see the idea
that this is the end of the matter he's
put a bird skilosh then came the most
crucial moment of the day would mps
effectively vote to delay their
meaningful vote and force the prime
minister to extend the brexit deadly
[Applause]
people came here thinking this was the
crunch moment do-or-die for the people's
vote well they've done an agree how long
there's still so much uncertainty it's
not good for the nation absolutely
appreciate that how much time has
anybody had to actually go through the
deal flanked by police officers even the
man charged with preparing for no deal
wasn't prepared to give his view on
where we go from here for Sky News on
how you feel this goes from here where's
this go from here mr. go
no one knows people's vote protesters
and their advocates in Parliament have
stopped nothing just slowed things down
as it stands the drums still beats
towards brexit Jason Farrell Sky News
you